the jurogan experience the physical
strain that you guys put your body
through is [ __ ] insane
and until you watch like you guys
compete
and do all the [ __ ] like rocking like
running with the weight vest
on and everything yeah it's insane yeah
yeah the games
so like the games are like the big
competition it's like
it's it's a wild show because it's
sometimes it's five days some
times it's three days and we'll have
like usually between 12 and 15 events
over those days do they let you know in
advance what you're gonna have to do
some like we might find out in the event
sometimes a week or two ahead
uh but then like we'll have others where
we're literally finding out the event as
we go
like as we're competing so we don't even
know what we're doing on the competition
floor they'll be
they'll be like all right start lifting
that weight we'll tell you when to stop
when you hit your number of reps
you know stuff like that it's uh
it's interesting to train for because
you don't know if you're training for a
one rep max
or a hundred uh you don't know if you're
training for a 40 meter dash
or a marathon you know it's yeah it
keeps it interesting
like we've had we've had events that are
like 20 seconds long and then
a couple years ago we had to row a
marathon on like the stationary concept
two rowers
so like 42 000 meters so was that 26.2
miles
rowing yeah yeah four yeah 42 000
something hundred years
i think the average time was about three
hours i think a couple people were like
three and a half hours yeah because you
can't row as
fast as you can run right can you
i mean i would prefer to row a marathon
than run one
just because it's easier on the joints
oh okay like your ass
goes numb just from sitting on the seat
um
but yeah i mean it was just easy on the
joints they did it because they were
like we tested it and like
after you run a marathon like you can't
walk for a couple days like your body's
just trashed
with rowing a marathon like you're sore
but you're good to go the next day
it really doesn't really though depend
on the person and what kind of condition
you're in because
my friend cam haines that [ __ ]
runs a marathon every day
yeah i think if you're conditioned for
and that's all you're doing yeah
you know and but he lifts weights too
yeah yeah i've met cam i met him a
couple years ago he's got problems
does he yeah he's crazy he's legit legit
crazy like david goggins crazy there's a
few people that i know
that i'm like what are you doing to
yourself yeah you know yeah i i
i'll watch cam and yeah runs a marathon
every day it's like why
what are you doing well that he likes
those ridiculous
ultra races like those the more i got
240s and stuff like that yeah i got a
buddy that does all those
like 200 mile couple days long
and it's like all right like i get that
that's your thing
i don't get it but more power to you
they're just
test i mean for cam he's just testing
his mind yeah
he wants to find out when it breaks you
know and he he can't break it
yeah and every day strengthens it so
every day he's running
massive amounts of miles he'll run like
19 miles in the morning
and he'll run like six miles in the
afternoon i mean i wonder if like if
he's ever played with like
other challenges you know instead of
just running because i know like
if i'm practicing the same thing over
and over you adapt to it you get better
at it you get more comfortable with it
and it's like when those curveballs get
thrown at you it's something that you're
not used to
and i mean that's basically that's
crossfit right that's what our training
is like we're trying to think of
different things that can be
be the test for us and figure out like
all right if this comes up
how do we deal with it how did you get
involved what was did you just walk into
a class one day and
get kind of funny so i have a background
in olympic weightlifting
did that for 10 years lived at the
olympic training center like
my goal was to go to the olympics for
weightlifting
and then that didn't pan out and
like started focusing on school and then
i just kind of i guess just gained the
freshman 15.
so i was like all right either need to
start working out again
or change my diet so i was like oh i'll
start working out
and uh you know trying to find an
olympic weightlifting gym
is there like a needle in a haystack
but crossfits are everywhere and so i
just like googled crossfit near me
because they they use all the same
equipment like the barbells and bumpers
and so i just showed up introduced
myself i was like hey like
i don't want to do your crossfit thing
i'll be in the back room just doing
cleaning jerks and squats and uh
just kept doing that kind of showing up
on a irregular basis and then
one of the girls from the gym who was a
competitor was just kind of like
bribing me into workouts every once in a
while like oh you might be good at this
one give this one a try give this one a
try
and the uh the owner of the gym
actually signed me up for my first
competition because he's okay i think
you have potential in this you should
give this a try
and uh so we made a deal that he signed
me up and paid my entry fee
and then if i won any money he i had to
buy a pair of crossfit shoes
and what are crossfit shoes i mean at
the time it was like
the reeboks like the minimalist shoes
like i was working out in air max 90s
and so he's like anything's better than
that and what year was this
this would be back in like 2012 and
uh so anyways i i won the competition
got a couple hundred bucks and was like
yo this is kind of cool like just pocket
money for a college kid
like are there more competitions like
this and so they showed me where to find
these competitions and i just kind of
started driving around the northeast
like all of new england and if there was
prize money at a competition
i was signing up and so i basically
looked at it like a part-time job of
like while i'm in school full-time and
broke i can make some pocket money
and uh yeah just kind of i was like
if i want to keep winning these
competitions i need to work on my
weaknesses get better and then
just kind of fell in love with it and it
just ratcheted up
bit by bit until like i'm at the world
championships and i'm like
oh [ __ ] how did that get here and then
you won
over and over and over again which is
crazy yeah it's a weird start man to
something that you
not just excelled at i mean i think
you're the winningest guy ever
right yeah i've won won the been on the
podium seven times
and i've won at the last five years
that's bananas
yeah i mean for someone who started off
as a lark yeah i'm
i'm not blind to it like i'll be sitting
with my fiance like
you know just when these cool
opportunities get plopped in front of me
and i'm like how how did i end up here
like this wasn't supposed to be my life
you know i was a mechanical engineer
you know like i thought my sports career
was over with
olympic weightlifting you know i broke
my back like it was a whole
what did you do to your back uh i broke
my l5 in two spots oh
yeah how uh just training too heavy too
often
and uh it just fractured the actual bone
yeah yeah like the little wings off the
side and it was on two separate
occasions too
they were like a week or two apart from
each other and
so wait hold on you broke one and then
you kept lifting
yeah i didn't really have a choice so i
was living at the olympic training
center and like there was a lot of
pressure
on the program to like produce and i was
on the junior world team
i was leaving for romania in a couple
weeks to compete and
uh yeah i was just i don't know i wasn't
training as smart as i should have been
and
so the first one was doing like a clean
pull so just like a dead lift with a big
explosion at the top
and like loud pop on one side and i
dropped the bar and like
it have you ever seen those heat packs
that have the little clicky thing in
them
it was that's what it felt like when it
like clicked and then it's just like
the inflammation just spreading and uh
and so you know go to my room lay down
for a couple days
and then you know it was oh i knew
something was
wrong like i've never had an injury like
that you know i couldn't move
did you get an x-ray did you get an mri
no because it was like
the i was leaving for the competition in
like two weeks so it was like too late
to call the alternate
to do they know that you're this injured
i mean i told them like hey i and
they're like suck it up
i'm injured and i was told like hey
there's a difference between pain and
injury
and i was like okay uh
i'll get back to lifting and so then
a couple days goes by and i'm being
super cautious like
basically stripped all the way out of my
training i'm just moving and then uh
what was it was heavy back squat and
like
load up and you're going for like a new
one rep max like a week before you get
on the airplane
and uh yeah hit the bottom of the hole
left side goes
oh jesus and so anyways i got went to
the competition
did terribly you know like
the coach was like hey what's your goal
for this competition i was like i just
don't want to bomb out
i just want to make one lift one lift in
each
and he's like okay we'll make sure that
happens i
i only made one snatch one cleaning jerk
and then it was when i got back
i like put my foot down i was like hey
i'm not i'm not lifting [ __ ] until i get
an x-ray
and like they x-rayed it and they're
like oh yeah there's break right here
right here
and what does the coach feel bad uh
i mean i feel for him now that i have a
little more life experience and like
you know at the time hated the guy um
but now that i know the situation he was
in he was under pressure
for keeping his job to like hey you need
to produce athletes like none of the
american athletes are
doing well on the world world scene
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all
for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience